Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 24th. Uh,
2017 was going on. How, why? Yeah,
I got to keep my voice down. I got my little,
little one here is sleeping and the next room I am in New York City.
I got a little acting Gig here on a little movie in a little city called New
York City. Um, for the next week I'll be doing that shit.
So I'm acting during the day and night whenever the hell they have me doing it.
And um, then I'm looking,
I come home and I look at the scripts that we're working on for F is for family
and um, I dunno,
that's become my life here. I actually did one spot this weekend though.
I went over to the Gotham comedy club,
hadn't been there in fucking years. Went over there,
had a great time and uh,
try to maybe pop in and do another spot maybe next weekend or something just to
get off. So, I don't forget all my fucking jokes, but, uh,
Jesus Christ Has New York changed? I can't believe it.
Like everybody lives in Brooklyn now.
Um,
I don't know. I mean there's a bunch of people still living in Manhattan,
but like, I don't know, Manhattan is a weird now. Like they, uh,
they took it too far. Like,
I remember when I first lived here, it's like Manhattan was, it was scary.
Like you were always kind of, you know,
being aware of people around you.
I remember buying like a jacket behalf,
trying to look tougher than I really was just trying anything you could do to,
you know,
okay,
keep that fucking thing off you. And I'm,
and even then,
I guess it was way better obviously than it was in the 70s and the crack
eighties and everything and Giuliani had just taken over. But uh,
somewhere along the line, man, they, they, they just took it too far.
I felt like I was in like Sacramento or something,
you know,
not saying there aren't dangerous parts of Sacramento,
those dangerous parts of her, it just felt like a dish.
It didn't feel like New York, like there was just no, there was no vibe,
I guess. It was kind of cool, you know, like families and Shit.
It kinda just, it's starting to feel like a theme park. Um,
I know that's a weird thing to complain about that it's, it's like too safe,
but it's just a, I don't know, probably just a grumpy old man.
It's definitely not the city I remember. So, um,
I was out in Brooklyn, you know,
rehearsing some of the shit that I get to do for next week and, um,
just going through that, oh my God. All the fucking high rise it. Oh my God.
All the fucking high rises and shit, they're building over there and um,
it's, it's just not, I've,
I remember I used to date this woman that fucking lived off the g train like
fucking 15 years ago and it was like,
it was like going into another fucking world.
Um, and uh,
now you go, I don't know what the fuck's going. I don't know.
I'm just an old man going, there's no way used to
me. Yeah, I went over there. That's like, we're all like the hipsters,
but even everybody is so anti hipster that even hipsters don't dress like
kippsters anymore. But you can still see them, you know?
Now the new vibe is you sorta like, yeah, Blake,
the Connor McGregor haircut with the good Charlotte tattoos and clothes,
you know, see kind of look like,
does this guy build custom motorcycles or does he ride a tricycle with the giant
front wheel? You know,
is he making his own brew is, you know,
is he working one of those fucking breweries and you know, it's none of that.
You know the Michael Jackson pants that don't quite make it down to your fucking
sneakers or shoes or whatever the fuck they are. So I don't know.
Like
Brooklyn's like, it's like nice now. I don't know
fucking it was,
yeah, Jesus Christ. What I want to know is when did all those people go
when they wiped it all up? Like where do,
where do all the rest of the people go? Where do all of those restaurants go?
Where does that vibe go? All that culture. Where the fuck does it go?
Everything just looks like a fucking forever 21 now.
And everything's just a giant glass luxury fucking apartment building.
Who the fuck has all this money?
I thought these fucking millennials were broke.
They were coming out of college with all this college debt and there were no
fucking jobs and all they do, you know,
okay,
I don't what's going on if you're trying to buy a house right now, it's like,
if you don't have, like you tried to buy a house and there's some Chinese guy or
guy from the Middle East or a Russian guy that just comes in and just fucking
[inaudible]
bids all cash.
I think this is my fucking conspiracy theory that Russia,
China in the Middle East, Aramco, hoots with each other and they're like, look,
well, we can't like just go over and start bombing those guys. You know,
the United States have nuclear weapons and as we saw in World War Two, uh,
they will use them not once, but twice, right?
So they know they can't do that.
So I think what they're doing now is they're just going to fucking,
just slowly buy as much as they can and put a Chinese guy,
a Russian or an Arab in all of those. And then they'll be,
they'll have infiltrated our country then
the run for office and then they'll just switch the whole fucking thing.
Do I sound like that guy talking about bottle are precious bodily liquids or
fluids in a doctor? Strange love. I don't fucking know. Um,
I think this is a part of being my age where like you live long enough that you
remember how it used to be and now you've seen it changing.
It's kind of freaking you out. Maybe that's what it is.
Maybe I'm just one of those guys being like wow, you know when I die some day,
like no one's going to give a fuck and this is just going to keep going isn't
it? I guess I'm not that important. Um,
anyways. Um,
I'm fucking got my handheld goddamn recorded here cause I'm,
yeah,
cause I'm on the road and I didn't have any room to bring all my podcasts shit
cause I got the kid now and uh,
that's a fucking trip, Huh? Packing up all your stuff,
all this stuff you need for the kid. Um,
yeah, I dunno, it's not that bad.
You just pack it all up and then you just go to curb side fucking hand somebody
a 20 and just be like, yeah, just shove all this shit under the plane.
Then that's it. And you get one of those giant wheelie things when you land,
you just wheel it out and you throw it all in a cab. Right.
Again, you yank it out and then you got the guy at the hotel,
you fucking pee puts it on a wheelie thing. It's, it's really not that bad.
Everybody acts like they have to carry it and fucking hold it in their lap on
the plane ride.
You don't just pay the extra money shoving under the fucking plate and be done
with it. Um, but my daughter did great on the plane. You know,
I guess kids before, they're like one years old. Like the, uh,
the air pressure stuff doesn't quite bug them as much. I don't know why.
Maybe there you stationed tubes, they're so small, they, I don't,
I don't understand why it wouldn't,
but people claim that it doesn't, you know,
and for those of you who don't understand that ear popping thing,
which I didn't, it's just, you know,
when you take off the air inside your ear on the other side of your ear drum
is a,
that pressure as you ascend becomes higher than the pressure on the other side
of the eardrum. The outside part, right? That leads to the a,
the little fucking escape patch on the side of your head. Right?
So there's that difference in air pressure.
We all know high pressure always goes to low pressure and it takes the most
direct route, which is, you know, pushing against your fucking ear drum. Um,
and then when you land, it's the exact opposite. So when you're going up,
your ear drum is getting pushed out because the pressure is higher there.
And then when you land it becomes the opposite. I believe that's correct. Right?
Yeah, that's right. Cause as, as you go back down again,
the pressure becomes higher outside your ear. That's all that's going on. Um,
and you can't explain that to them, baby.
I was barely able to explain it to you. Um, so anyways,
she did great on the plane. She slept a lot. And then when she wasn't, you know,
I just got up and I was walking around with her and uh, you know,
the flight attendants loved them and who doesn't love a baby. Right.
And fortunately my daughter's like really cool.
She's got this thing where she just kinda like,
she's met so many people already that she's not freaked out by people.
So when she meets someone new, she just like, you know,
borderline in a rude way, just stares at them. And it takes a like a good,
like three minutes. And then eventually she's like, all right,
I get to this person is,
and then she smiles and then turns away into your chest. She gets a little shy.
Um, oh, would you look who's here? Will you look who's here?
And she gives me a wave and there she goes, you're going to come back out.
All right. Um, yeah,
so we able to do that and it wasn't that bad. And uh, this is kind of cool.
Like I'm a [inaudible] back in New York,
but the whole family makes doing the road way better.
I can tell you that now we just have to convince my wife to come along with me
with our daughter, woman. I go to like the not fun places.
He's given a shit about that, you know, she's always good to support me.
You know, when I go to a fun city, you know,
but when I go to like fucking Jacksonville, Florida, I'm on my own, you know,
which is really bullshit because I have a lot of fun in that town. You know,
eat a little bit of alligator. You go to a gun range, why not? Anyways,
let's try and bring the energy up here. This is a fucking hard one to do.
It's hard to do. When I got to keep my voice down, you know. Um, anyways,
so I'm totally back into my New York vibe. You know,
I really missed what I had lived in.
The sense of living on the west coast is a really missed the yes network.
Um, when I lived here at 10 years ago,
I can't fucking believe that I've been in La for 10 fucking years. Um,
I used to always, you know,
I would watch the yes network and root against the Yankees.
That was like my shit. I never watched the mets.
I could never get into the fucking meds, but that's what I would do.
I would watch almost every single Yankee game as many of them as I could. Um,
or I'd watch the replays when I got home and I would just sit there and I would
just root against them. But I mean, you had to watch them.
They were like this tour to $1 billion juggernaut.
And I used to always go to Yankee stadium.
I'd go by myself cause I lived on the east side. You'd just jump on the fucking,
what is that, the four, five, six,
take it right up to the Bronx old Yankee stadium,
which was actually renovated old Yankee stadium.
And I would sit in like the fucking upper deck for like 12 bucks and keep score
like an old man. And I used to watch Clemens and uh,
was it Mike Muse, Siena, that whole era. But I remember like in 1998, you know,
the 1998 Yankees, I got to go to a couple of a couple of games that year,
no one full well that I was watching what looked like was going to be one of the
great teams of all time. And you know, 20 years later I still believe that.
And um, but I used to fucking root against them, especially Clemons.
I used to root against that guy hard. And um,
but so if I lived here once again,
I would be going to games because uh, now they got Aaron,
judge and I, Jesus' needy. Um,
you looking good. Um, anyways,
I used to always go up there and I would just root against it.
But now they got Aaron judge and even the Red Sox Fan,
you got to give it up to the fucking Yankees to the greatest franchise of all
time is as far as spotting talent.
Do you realize for basically the last 80 out of 100 years,
that'd be a century. Near a hundred years is a century.
You understand that? Huh? Well,
you clamming up where you going right now?
Okay. Um,
for the last 80 out of the last 100 years,
they have scouted and picked the guy.
There's no other fucking franchise out there that can say it. They fought okay.
They bought Babe Ruth. All right.
The Red Sox fucking owner was so goddamn pussy wet.
He had to keep his fucking wife quiet and she wanted to fucking,
I don't even know what the play was, you know,
but he needed to finance her fucking Broadway play to just shut her the fuck up.
And he sells babe Ruth. No excuse for that.
It's not like we didn't know who the fuck he was.
The guy was winning cy young awards and hitting the fucking zillion home runs,
and we still get rid of them because this fucking lady had to get a little tap
dance, fucking Fauci shit going right?
So they don't get credit for that one.
That was a dumb move by the fucking red sox and everybody knew the babe was the
shit. However, this is what they'd done for the last 80 fucking years.
All right. From their farm system,
they went Lou Gehrig to Joe Dimaggio to Mickey Mantle.
Right. Then June, then they added a little dip. George Steinbrenner comes in,
you know the Oakland A's don't want to pay anybody.
He buys the Fuckin Oakland A's. They went to championships. Fuck all of that.
And he buys Dave Winfield. Fuck all of that. A bad 2025 years in there.
Okay. Then fucking Derek Jeter,
I forgot. Oh wait, I forgot what's his face? Don Mattingly.
You know the reason why people don't look at him like he's one of the greatest,
cause he never won a fucking world series.
But don Mattingly to Derek Jeter,
to Aaron judge, you can argue with me on don Mattingly.
He wasn't quite one of the greats of the greats,
but like this fucking Aaron judges,
it's like Paul Bunyan's coming up to the plate,
six foot seven just did you see that whole money yet against Seattle the other
night? He almost fucking hit it out of the stadium.
You're not supposed to be able to do that. He hit it so hard, so fucking far.
They, they, they, they could measure it.
I think these are like 440 feet, which, you know,
I've heard of shit going farther, but it's like,
that's just cause the stop top of the stadium stopped it. Um,
Jesus, oh, Seattle pitches get lit up, don't they?
Do you ever see that one McGuire hit off of Randy Johnson?
You almost put a hole in the roof of the fucking kingdom. Um, yeah.
That was a brutal combination of like,
like a hundred mile an hour pitch meeting. Fucking Andrew Steam,
whatever the fuck he was on. Um,
if you're old enough to remember what it was like to watch a roided up
professional athlete hitting baseballs and watching that fucking laser show that
those guys put on, I don't think you can argue
that steroids definitely should be in the game. They'd to be like,
all they gotta do is just work on the side effects and just get it down.
Just like weed. You know you've got the, at the vaporizer.
Just if they can like vape arise like steroids.
Can you imagine that we pull a muscle or whatever the fuck you feel like an old
man.
He'd just just breathe in that missed you fucking muscles repair like a goddamn
x man and every day feels like the first day of spring.
Oh my God. Am I spending Tony Bennett every,
if I ruled the world every day would be like the first day of spring.
So they'd done it at like [inaudible] with Aaron judge. I just had that,
that's the greatest fucking franchise of all time is far as their ability to see
the guy. No, the guy is the guy. And somehow sign them before anybody else.
I don't know how the fuck they do it.
Like how does everybody else miss out on Aaron? Judge.
I could see missing out in Derek Jeter. You know,
I could definitely see that he was a kid, you know, and another six, three, six,
four fucking guy. I mean this a zillion of those,
but a six foot seven guy coming up there like the fucking jolly green giant.
Like how do you miss that guy somehow everybody does. Um,
I know there's probably some people out there arguing for the Lakers and I got
to give respect to the Lakers as,
as in my lifetime from 1968 until now,
the Los Angeles Lakers have won more championships than anybody else in my
lifetime. Believe it or not, it is the Lakers,
they won a c they won like one in the 70s.
Five in the 80s. That's a, that's six.
And then they won.
Yeah,
they want five with Colby and a thousand fucking free agents.
Um, so that's 11.
And, uh,
the only person that comes close to that in my lifetime would be the Canadians
where they wanted 68, 69,
71737670770 870-NINE-8Y-69TY three they want 10.
Um, [inaudible] anyways, but I don't kind of like the Lakers,
like
the real story of the Los Angeles Lakers is fucking free agents. You know,
like when they always stay,
we just try to get someone to join and become part of the history of the Great
Lakers centers in every one of them is a fucking free agent except for the first
giant white dude that George, whatever the fuck his name was,
I'm going to send mirror son. What the fuck was that guy's name? I don't know.
He looked like a giant science teacher and he actually played with Minneapolis.
Mike in the fuck was his name. I can't remember. Anyways,
then you got Kareem, he was a Milwaukee Buck, right.
Shaq, like they're all just fucking, you know, wilt,
they're all just from someplace else.
So I have a bad feeling that fucking Lebron James is going to go out there and
that the Lakers are eventually,
you know,
despite whatever Danny Ainge does, I just think it's inevitable that the Lakers,
it will pass the Celtics as far as number of championships because for the
simple fact, we cannot offer what the Lakers can offer.
I've said this before, like this is our pitch. Hey, you know,
do you want to come to racist Boston with Shitty fucking weather and Bang sixes
or do you want to go to racist fucking Los Angeles,
fuck movie stars and feel like you're in Hawaii with the weather.
You know what I mean? We can, we can't fucking compete with that.
We can't compete with that. So that's, that's fucking it. Now, you know,
and then like our colors, you know, our fucking mascots, a Goddamn Leprechaun.
I mean we just can't get any wider. The Lakers have like, you know,
you know the, the colors is somebody that has no money but they want,
they want to fucking look like they're doing something.
That's fine.
That's what the Lakers colors up with the gold. And the purple,
you know what I mean? The Lakers just screamed new money.
Like you remember when you used to watch those MTV cribs and you'd watch some
fucking idiot, you know,
with the giant fucking need to have like a fish tank in his fireplace. You know,
yet the fire still works on, you know, like those, you look at that shit,
you're like, this guy's going to go fucking broke in.
This guy's going to go pro.
Like he's got like 20 people hanging out in his fucking house.
This guy's going to go broke. That's when I look at the Lakers uniform.
That's what I see. Especially those old road ones, those purple ones.
Um, I dunno, I always thought that their uniforms were a little silly.
I liked the home ones, but the road ones always looked really silly to me. Um,
but anyways, where I was for just like, you know, green and white,
we gotta fucking, Oh, a topic. Oman until, yeah, fucking mascot.
I mean, I can't imagine what Danny Ainge has to say to people to try to get them
to come to Boston. No, no, no, no.
The n word that was shouted at a red sox game this year. Not at a Celtics game.
It's fucking brutal. Um, having said that though,
I feel like the cops in La beat the shit out of black people way more.
I don't know. It's a push as far as like the racism, it's a real,
it's a push. You know,
people always sit there and they try to act like all the racism is in the south
and in Boston. But you go out to la, it's fucking ridiculous.
They got all the black people quarantined, you know, in this little area.
That's coincidentally enough, final approach for fucking lax.
They got goddamned jets flying over their fucking heads every day,
fucking 500 feet off the fucking ground for runways all day long.
People just landing on final fucking approach. You know,
that wouldn't make you fucking be in a certain mood. I know what would make, um,
anyways, let me read a little bit of advertising here.
I know my stomach is grumbling here.
This always happens when I have the fucking, uh, the recording here.
So I'm on my fucking, I have acting work diets so I don't, uh,
I go 12 hours without from the last time I ate and ate about 10 o'clock last
night. Something and have to deal with the grumbling and the grumbling here.
Alright. Oh Jesus, look who's back everybody. Oh my God. It's our old friends.
Old Zip.
[inaudible]
screwed up. I'm sorry, I can't yell this,
she's still sleeping in the other room. Um, are you hiring well, are Ya,
do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates? How, how Zipper,
uh, the fuck is this? Talk about the challenge of finding great talent and,
or importance of finding great talent to successful business. Well,
I think it's self explanatory and I'm a one man show here,
so I don't know what to tell you. Uh, with ZipRecruiter,
you can post your job to 100% 100 plus job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful technology efficiently matches the right people to your job
better than anyone else. That's why zip
the group is different. Unlike other recite zip
doesn't depend on candidates finding you. It finds them. In fact,
over 80% of jobs posted on ZipRecruiter get qualified candidates in just 24
hours. It's like a dating app, except you're not going to fuck them.
You're going to make them go to work, right?
No juggling emails or calls in your office.
Simply screen rate and manage candidates all in one place with ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use dashboard. Find out today why zip
rigor has been used by businesses of all sizes to find the most qualified job
candidates with immediate results.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on zip recruiters.
Separate Group for free. That's right free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/burn that's ziprecruiter.com/bar one more time.
Try It for free. Go to zip
recruiter.com/burb all right. Oh, look who's back. Oh,
would you look who's back? Bodo ds me undies.
Los Angeles has races to do. Do, do,
do B and ds B and Ds. If you don't believe me as good Jew,
I don't know why they would know. They look white to me,
but Dava Dubbo, I don't know.
I'm fucking white and I could do whatever I want. I'm
sorry, I just woke up. I haven't had my fucking cereal yet. Um,
Mandy's everybody, me undies are the softest,
most comfortable underwear you'll ever wear. Period.
And summer is the perfect time to upgrade your underwear drawer because everyone
is thinking about looking good and feeling good and me and these are the
ultimate feel good undies. MMM. Hey man,
they just make my undercarriage field right. You know, it's like,
you know what you know, you feel when you listen to easy listening.
Just imagine your balls feeling like that.
That's what it's like wearing this underwear.
Every pair of me undies is sustainably sourced and made from micro modal modal
of fabric that's three times softer than cotton.
If you're used to buying boring underwear, Mandy's will change everything.
Um, I think underwear is exciting. It's like buying new socks. You know,
you feel a little spring in your step. Same thing except it's with your Dick.
Because me undies come in all kinds of colors and patterns and they release new
limited edition patterns each month that always sell out.
This month's patterns were designed by the legendary eighties clothing brand.
Cross colors with names that live up to their bold designs and bright colors
increased to peace. You dig and the, Oh gee,
what the fuck is this? Is that for like fucking black guys over in the,
in their 50s?
That all sounds like late eighties shit that was spray painted onto somebody's
jeans. Um,
you gotta see them for yourself and right now you'll save 20% off your first
pair and receive free shipping only at [inaudible] dot com slash burn there's a
reason Mandy's has sold over 5 million pairs to date.
You'll feel it when you put them on Jesus Christ. What's it going to give you?
A handy there. And if you don't love your first pair of me undies, they're free.
You get 20% off your first pair plus free shipping at Mandy's dot com slash bird
that's [inaudible] dot com slash bar one more time.
[inaudible] dot com slash bar I know what the fucking problem is.
I usually have my headphones on.
That usually helps with the comedy if he can hear yourself.
I don't know what it is. You kind of need to hear yourself. Hang on a second.
I gotta get a cause here. All right, there we go. Now we're back.
Now I can hear myself. Okay, now the comedies on fucking now.
Now here comes the fuck.
Here comes the comedy that I read everything yet.
Oh doll I'll do all is shave club. Dollar Shave Club, dude.
Dollar Shave Club. It's this mad at choice a,
you'll get a great shave at a great price.
Conveniently delivered right to your Doula. Uh,
you no longer have to Schlep to this store. Oh look at that. Using Yiddish.
Now buy a cheap disposable razor that give you a cheap shave or spend a fortune
on razors with gimmicky shaving technologies that you don't fucking need when
you use the dollar shave club executive razor with Dr cabbies.
Easy shave
the blade gently glides over your ball bag, giving you a smooth shave.
Dr Carver's shave butter. You know, most porn stars,
most male porn stars use Dr Carver's shave butter on the fucking scrotum.
You know, if you ever wonder when you're watching it, you know
if you get distracted by the smooth balls, you're like, yeah, you know?
Well how did he get that way? Well, there you go.
Now you know if you weren't porn star balls,
get Dr Carver's shave butter a, it's transparent.
For Way more precise shave helps prevent ingrown hairs and fight razor bumps.
Make the smarter choice by joining Dollar Shave Club for a limited time.
New members get their first month of the executive razor with a tube of their
doctor.
Could have easy shave for only $5 with free shipping and after that,
razors are just a few bucks a month. That's $15 or $15 value for only $5.
Look at that. There's no hidden phase and no commitments.
Cancel anytime you like.
You can only get this offer exclusively@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr that's
dollar shave club.com/bar all right, let's get back to the podcast.
Let's get back to the podcast, the whip up, up, up, up.
Bo and I'll else that I want to talk about.
I Dunno if I have anything else to talk about. Too busy stressing out,
getting picked
up by the sad van, the sad van that always takes you to this set.
It's a bare bones van.
It's always white with either gray or black vinyl interior.
And you just get in there and you're just like, I don't know.
I find it very stressful, this acting shit, you know what I mean?
Um, because I never could just focus on the day.
I always look at it like I'm always looking at the entire shoe.
Like I've already thought like, you know, you know,
this time next week I'll be done. You know,
rather than trying to enjoy it.
So I learned a long time ago,
but I can't say I learned it cause I'm still stressing about it.
But I've just kind of learned to be like, okay, you know,
I am just going to just fucking deal with today when it comes to these acting
gigs and just be like,
we are doing this scene and I've got to make these choices and this is what I'm
going to do and I'm going to listen to the fucking director if he wants it this
way, I'll do it that way and bucket that [inaudible] and then that'll be it.
And then I'll go home and then I'll memorize the lines for the next day and then
I'll just fucking do that. And I just,
rather than fucking looking over the horizon,
just dealing with that fucking day, you know? I know that sounds fucking weird,
but that's how I have to do it. Cause if I don't do it that way, then I, I, uh,
you know what I mean?
It's the kind of thing that stops you from fucking looking at your taxes,
If you're incorporated and you play like quarterly taxes and shit, you know,
or refute. If you don't pay quarterly,
you got like the end of the years I fucking,
I ended up every month I get my receipts together, I get everything.
It fucking sucks but only sucks for like an hour, you know what I mean?
As opposed to waiting the entire fucking year and it takes like three days to
get through this shit. Um,
it also lets me know what the fuck I'm spending and um,
and all of that type of ship. So did that make any sense?
Cause it didn't even make sense to me. All right.
Why don't I just get out of this shit and I'm just going to read a few of these
questions, a couple of these questions. All right. On the arm.
All right,
for those of you who listen to this podcast religiously or maybe cut the last
one. Um,
I was asking like how that expression came about cause I brought it up in the
writer's room. I use a fourF is for family. I was talking about a,
it's on the arm and it lose a number of people that had never heard that
expression. And I said, well, it means, yeah, it means it's free.
You don't have to pay for it. Um, and then when I was looking it up,
trying to figure out where it came from, it said it was a, a m
it came from like law enforcement or whatever.
But evidently I was wrong cause someone else went to another part of the
Internet and they came up with this. It said, Bill,
here's what the internet said about on the arm or is what you found that it
said,
because what I found that has said was above those from came from the fucking
law enforcement eat this person, uh,
to show their respects to the mafia boss who protected their neighborhood.
Um, or fear of being extorted.
The store owners would not allow them to pay for items. Well,
if you're afraid that you're going to be extorted,
I don't think that like bowing down to somebody.
You should make them fucking pay for it, I would think. But anyways, um,
the store owners would take their right hand and brush it against their left arm
as a way of saying, forget about it. No charge free.
All right. Well where I looked at it that it came from,
it came from law enforcement. The the cops wouldn't pay for stuff. I don't know.
You get me. Who the fuck knows? It's the Internet. You don't know what's true.
You don't know what isn't right. How far did you look?
How far onto the Internet did you go?
I'm going to see how far it took me to get. Okay. On the arm here we go.
On the arm
origin.
Okay.
Come on in. Come on. Internet work for me on the arm. Any idea do was origin.
Is it that the police might have threatened with his gun?
I doubt it but I'm just trying to figure out this is what I get.
That's the first one. The first one.
It's just one of these.
What are these fucking chat rooms by the way and who and who are these people in
him? Where are these things? How do you chime into these things?
You get to sign in on,
I'm on like word reference.com and this guy just writes or this woman writes,
hi there. I heard the phrase on the arm in the movie,
Donnie Brasco about a Mafia guy,
Al Buccino as an undercover policeman. Parentheses,
Johnny Depp is their movie. That old,
he could've just said fucking Donnie Brasco people that was in it.
I learned that it's police lingo for free of charge.
Any idea as to its origin?
Is it that the policemen might have threatened with his gun?
I doubted, but I'm just trying to figure the arm in there.
Wait, why would you present a theory and then doubt your own fucking theory?
Um,
it was what the People's response was.
Okay. Dictionary georeference reference somebody who has this click on this arm.
Okay.
The upper limb of the human body, especially part extending from the shoulder
up. There was a series, the upper limb from the show you the formula,
the verb base, any arm like attachment
and administrative or operational branch of an organization and arm and a leg is
a great deal of money. Ah, arm and arm,
arms linked together and arms length on the arm,
a slang free of charge.
And investigation of policemen who ate lunch on the arm.
Uh, put the arm on to solicit or borrow money from.
She put the arm on me for a generous contribution to force or use violence on
you strung up. I, you know what, I don't even give a shit.
This is what happened. By the time it gets to this part of the Internet,
it's like I don't fucking care.
And there's usually something I can click on in this side. Like,
oh look at Tyson. Keep it real. Keep it Tyson. Check them out.
I guess it's some sort of fucking lunch meat.
Luxury now what about me fucking I guess cause it's on the arm.
Like they think somebody wants a free sandwich.
Catch it at a store near you.
Some giant fish. Oh, where do the day Highfalutin.
That's a word I thought that was just something you s you send me sandwich.
Say Dag burn. Highfalutin. Varmint um,
Dominic was at the back at a back table talking to a suited man in the som Bray
in the somber,
Highfalutin English she put on for four people of stature.
Oh, it's like Madonna in this case. Probably the noodle salesman.
I have no idea what that sentence meant.
And I probably mispronounced most of it, but Donna puts on the fake accent,
you know,
why does she not act like she's just some white trash chick from Detroit?
She got that stupid English accent now. Uh,
[inaudible] still love it. Some. All right.
Solution to dude's girlfriend with the gross teeth. Oh my God.
Well this fucking story ever end. Hey Billy,
ginger Vidas ah, that's a clever one.
I found a real easy solution for the dudes that's,
that's dating the girl with gross teeth. Yes. So did I dumper?
All you gotta do is when you're sitting down to watch a movie just happened to
put on Austin Powers.
There's a couple of different scenes where the woman,
Austin is trying to bang,
hint hints that Austin needs to brush his gross fucking teeth.
This would be a good subtle way for a girl to realize that maybe she should take
care of her own teeth because believe me, she knows they're disgusting.
W W who walks around know that they stink when should do something about that.
And plus, I don't think that, you know,
if you're with somebody who's overweight, if you put it on the clumps, you know,
the nutty professor. I mean,
I think it'll just make them feel self conscious and bad about themselves and
make the, the overweight person want to go fucking binge eat more.
I don't know what the gross tooth person does. I go eat some fucking
fucking head cheese with a, I don't know, some onions. I Dunno. Anyways,
he said you could maybe even say something during the scene like, yeah,
why do British t people have gross teeth?
Okay.
He goes, I don't know. Probably won't work, but it's worth the try.
Is this everybody just shits on their own theories. Yeah. Dude, this won't work.
You know, it won't work, but it was worth it for your Billy ginger Vidas there.
Uh, also built, uh, have you been doing any grilling or smoking this summer?
I recently did some smoked chicken wings and they were the best wings I've ever
ate. Hands down. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. No, my,
my, uh, my grill,
my big green egg and my flat top grill have been like,
you know, if they were a car, I'd have them up on blocks right now. I just been,
um, so swamped with the work,
um, you know, and I get the kid and it's just like,
I dunno, I occasionally I will crank the thing up and I get into it,
but I'm a bit spent super, super fucking busy writing, writing and writing,
but I go taste sentiment. I actually really enjoy writing. Like, um,
I like, I hate the notes part and having to pull it apart.
I get frustrated with that, but that's,
it really is part of it. And people always goes, well, you know what they say?
Writing is rewriting. And I always want to be like, yeah. Is that what they say?
She said No.
Like, whatever the fuck he do for a living. Can you imagine if you just fucking,
if you feel,
if you put in floors and you put it in all the floors and then somebody comes in
and tells you to rip up most of it, you know, and you're like, really? And Yeah,
you know what flooring is? Flooring is re flooring.
Once you want to just take the board and just fucking smash your own head in
with it too. You just weren't consciously,
you wouldn't have to live that life anymore. Well, that's the life of a writer.
But I actually, uh,
I really find that I like doing it and I think just by hanging out with, uh,
all of these writers that have been doing it for so long,
obviously they're way better at it than I am, but you just kind of,
okay.
Start to absorb.
Yeah.
How to write stories and shit like that, which was always my problem.
I could always write dialogue,
but I just couldn't get the story from the beginning to the end.
Like my brain just didn't work that way. I could write scenes.
I think that's why I became a comedian because I bits like, oh, look at that.
That's a funny joke. That's a funny little scenario and done.
I don't have to fucking take the ball from the one yard line all the way to the
end zone like, like writers have to, you know, I was on special teams.
I was a wedge breaker.
That was it.
That was the fucking level of artistry that I was doing there.
What am I up to here? 41 minutes out. Jesus Christ.
Bill 41 minutes of fucking mediocrity. All right. Microchipping.
Oh God. Don't even get me started on this.
Yeah,
I just cannot fucking but like,
okay,
I just can't fucking believe this shit.
Do you know Delta Airlines wants to start using people's fingerprints?
It's a way for you to get on the fucking plane and do you know that most people
won't have a problem with it? This so fucking stupid.
It's like there's so many people out in the world. It's almost like,
you know what, dude? Why don't you just become a fucking slave? Like,
how much are you going to give to these people?
How underpaid are politicians that they will not stand up to these people,
these corporations, I swear to God,
they sitting there wasting all this fucking time with Isis and all this other
bullshit. These fucking corporations, the mothers,
the shit that they're doing to their own goddamn country man,
which they really don't have because they're fucking global.
They don't give a shit about anything about just trying to make more fucking
money and they want, they're going to start microchip and people.
This Wisconsin,
Wisconsin Company to implant Mike Implant microchips in employees
and likes like five people already agreed to it.
They're going to take something foreign that's not natural to your body and
they're going to stick it underneath your fucking skin.
They're going to know where you are at all fucking times and all these fucking
dope blue hair. You know? [inaudible]
problem is the fucking problem. Okay?
Just because you're a fucking dope doesn't mean the rest of the world is okay.
I think it's safe to say that me and everybody else listening to this thing,
for the most part was not as smart, is fucking George Washington. Right?
Fair enough. Okay, well, here's the deal.
If George Washington was microchipped and all his fucking buddies were
microchipped,
this fucking country wouldn't exist because he would've known where he was.
They would've gone over there and they would have fucking killed him.
And that would've been the end of the fucking rebellion.
So what you're doing is,
is you're having faith that these fucking people at the top who have not even
remotely demonstrated on any fucking level at any point in history,
that they give a flying fuck about anybody other than themselves are gonna.
You're going to turn over that level of power.
You're gonna get fingerprinted by Delta fucking airlines.
Like you've committed some sort of a fucking crime and fucking airline is going
to have your fucking fingerprints. Who in the fuck did they think they are?
Do you know what I want to buy my car? They asked for my thumbprint. I was like,
I'm not getting my fucking fingerprints to you're a car dealership. They legal.
This is to protect you. No, it isn't get Douche.
You're going to sell this to somebody. It's part of my profile.
I think they just, they're collecting,
they're all sharing information about you, what you buy, where you live,
what your social security number is. You fucking fingerprints.
They're going to get it all the way down to your fucking DNA.
It's an it's, I dunno.
Okay.
And these politicians will not push back on any level because the president
makes 500 grand a year.
That's the highest paid political office is 500 fucking grand a year.
And they need $100 million. Get the job. I don't have 100 million.
You don't have 100 million corporations do. And that's who they all were too.
So they just look the other fucking way. And what do they do?
They sit there and they shit on fucking comedians constantly going up to do you
hear what he said about Caitlyn Jenner and they look the other way with
pharmaceutical companies handing out fucking opiates.
Like they've given out flyers to some sort of jam band.
And now we've got this heroin fucking problem. They don't give a fuck.
They don't say anything about it. Sorry. I know I'm fucking losing my shit here.
But like,
okay,
what they've done to the food supply, what the fuck they,
they that what the bankers have done left all these people upside down in their
own fucking houses. What they've done to the water supply,
fracking causing earthquakes in parts of the world that never had fucking
earthquakes. Fucking up the drinking water.
Okay.
You know,
they got to send a fucking pipeline under the fucking native Americans land.
I mean, like, like we haven't done enough to those fucking people.
You know? Do you hear any politicians talking about that now?
Nobody talks about that shit. But God for fucking bid,
you'd do a fucking joke in a strip mall and it fucking all over it.
Then that becomes like some big goddamn story. Um,
this is fucking horrific and it makes me happy that I'm 49 years of age.
The fact that I think I'm going to maybe get to live half a fucking century
without a fucking airline having my fingerprints and me walking around with the
goddamn microchip. You know, I love that.
I lived 50 years before the fucking oh Jesus, she's up. Huh.
Um, I love that it got to live 50 years before robots showed up.
Um, it's just,
it's just greed and power. Completely.
100% out of control.
And I hate like this is, I'm reading this,
this is eye witness ABC News. So these guys are all bought and paid for.
CNN is bought and paid for a Fox News is bought and paypal,
they're all fucking bought and paid for because the same people I just brought
brought up, they advertise on their fucking networks.
So they have to watch what they say
cause they don't want to lose the ad money cause that's how they get paid.
Right. So they always have like the, oh Geez, this is a little unsettling.
You know when they always come back from it,
when they show some fucking robot and you've ever seen that and watched the
local news or they show somebody getting microchip and they always come back to
the anchors and they kind of do that, Ooh, that's kind of a,
and then they just move on to the next thing.
But some fucking old lady who makes her own jam,
like that's supposed to make you feel better at the end of the fucking newscast
or some puppy that they thought was lost and fucking sniffed its way back to the
station wagon, three towns away, right? Whenever the fuck they leave you on.
Um, no.
Corporations are completely out of control.
They've been out of control entire life
and now it's,
it's reaching a level that it's like you're watching a bad scifi movie.
I think it's fucking insane. Why?
Why the fuck do you need my fingerprints as a fucking airline?
Who the fuck are you? You're not the FBI. You're not the government.
You're fucking airline
your fingerprints. And this is the thing people will do.
People will fucking do all of this. So they don't have to stand in a line
bill, let them scan their fucking retina.
They'll give them a fucking baby just so they can be pretty checked.
That's all you gotta do.
You just hold a little cookie out and the average fucking mouth breathe and
fucking more. But you know something. I go, I swear to God.
I mean this is really cynical, but I,
you walk around and I forget half the fucking people should be microchipped.
You should know where these fucking idiots are.
That's that. That's that. Yeah.
I'll never forget that guy gallop in sideways on that Trump rally screaming at
all these stupid liberals. Go and fuck political correctness. Build the wall,
build the wall is he's fucking Gallup and like,
like that was gonna make his life better.
Like that was what was holding him back. I swear to God,
like,
I don't give a fuck how dumb you are.
You have to know as a white dude if you were born in the United States of
America, okay,
you're not going to get a better starting block than that.
All right? And if you can't figure out some sort of gay, I mean,
if you're going to fucking blame anybody, why are you going to look down?
You got to go up. That's what's fucking you over.
Democrats and Republicans fucking you over.
I just don't get how people don't see that. Um, but I'm like most people,
I feel like my ideas are right and no one else has a good point.
Um,
unreal. This fucking car dealership, can we get your thumbprint? It's like,
yeah, no, you guys sell cars. Do you understand that?
You guys lie for a living?
Other salesman who lie for a living turn the other way.
You let you turn the other way. When they see a car salesman you like to add
you like the bottom of the barrel fucking salesman here.
I'm going to give you my fingerprint.
You know why they said they wanted my fingerprint?
They go just in case somebody comes in and tries to,
okay.
Is An impostor and pretends that they're you and tries to buy a car.
And I just looked at the guy and I was like, you know what?
I'm going to take my chances on that.
Okay, did
the guy literally goes, this is what killed me. He goes,
you're the first person we've ever have say no to that.
Now I hope he's just being a car salesman.
And he was lying to me and that was his last ditch effort to try to convince me.
Um,
but the other part is actually telling the truth. It's just like,
then what happens is what?
This is how they do it is most people are adults.
So they don't think,
and then what happens is it becomes a herd mentality and all they gotta do is
get most of the herd to start running over the fucking cliff. And you,
you have to do it too. Cause if you don't,
then you're just going to be fucking sitting there all by yourself. Like, Hey,
I'm not gonna have a cell phone. Hey, I'm not going to have this.
I'm not going to have that. And then your life,
the way you're going to lead it becomes extremely limited.
And next thing you know,
you're fucking half naked walking around your backyard trying to s like trap
squirrels,
seek and eat that day because you're not doing what everybody else is doing and
it's just, you know, it's going to be the worst is when they try to convince,
uh,
when they tried to convince people to do it right.
There's going to be some politician getting it with that fucking smile on his
face where he's like, I don't want to do this but I have to do this.
I have to do this so I can go on the post president fucking,
you know,
$70 million speaking tour where I go out and I give speeches to the same fucking
people that put me into office. Like the hero of all hero presidents.
Obama is about to do. He just,
he has that motherfucker has $69 million with the gigs on the books
coming up. You know,
I will never, for the life of me understand why that guy,
people look like liberals.
Look at that guy like he fucking did something for him. I will never get that.
It's like that guy had his face in the pig trough just like everybody else.
I mean, I dunno. I Dunno what it is.
I think it's because he's sandwiched between two of the worst public speakers of
all time, Bush and fucking Trump. You know what I mean?
I think if he came after Clinton where Clinton wasn't the greatest, Whoa, whoa,
whoa, Whoa, whoa. But he got enough. The women fucking loved them.
I will never get that either. How much women love that fucking big fucking baby?
He, we look at goofball. Uhm, Jesus Boulder or any presidency you liked?
Yeah, I lied in mind.
The first George Bush fucking war hero and I liked, uh,
I liked Jimmy Carter. Um, anyways. All right.
B of a outage.
Uh,
hey banker bill. I work for B of a and from the customer service side,
that outrage was very stressful. If you haven't already mentioned it.
Slash found out the outrage was a result
of a,
Oh, Jesus Christ. This guy works for the fucking bank. He's going to,
he's going to tell me what happened. And you can't even spell the words were,
I don't, I don't know. You wrote half a word here, buddy.
S. E. V. E. R a sever reboot.
Is that supposed to be a severe reboot is several word. I don't know.
Maybe I'm wrong. Uh, I was told from my boss, my boss,
his boss in passing, when he was leaving work,
one of the tech guys managing the server ran a program to check for viruses and
shit. Okay. This guy manages your money,
checked for viruses and Shit and oh God.
He talks like me and the program
made [inaudible]
Jesus Christ in the program made that one particular server to shut down causing
the rest of our online products to not work.
That's the sentence by a guy who works at a bank.
The program made that one particular server to shut down to shutdown.
The program made that one particular service shut down. Is that what you mean?
Causing the rest of our online products to not work.
The bank had to restart all the servers to sync that tech crap up resulting in
the six hour delay from the call center side.
We could still see all the balances and account information.
Clients themselves just couldn't process any maintenance.
Okay.
Nothing made my day more enjoyable than apologize into client after client for
our system error. Had a few people in the situation you mentioned on Thursday,
what,
where are they stuck outside the country with no money. Oh,
had a few people in the situation you mentioned on Thursday where they are stuck
outside the [inaudible]. This guy is a fucking,
this guy who should've been in summer school next to me. Totally agree.
You need to have backup plans when it comes to accessing your money,
whether it be multiple bank accounts or stuffing some cash underneath the pillow
where you rest your bulb freckled dome at night. Keep doing what you're doing.
Uh, and go fuck yourself. Yeah.
I've never met a banker that believes in the banking system.
If you really talk to them about it, they're nervous too.
I Dunno. Anyways. Uh,
was that supposed to make me feel better? I mean,
I guess it's good that no one hacked into your system.
You guys just kind of were running something and something got fucked up. Um,
but he agreed with me. Yeah, I have a little money here. A little money there.
A little money there. Don't have it all your eggs in one basket.
We all know that. Right?
Cause then everything's going to be on the arm with the fucking one flew over
the cuckoo's nest. All right. Much older man. Okay, here we go. Well,
let me just tell you about that. Oh, 56. Okay. I mean there, I'm in there.
All right. Much older man. Bill Burr. How, why Ya,
I been listening to your pod. Oh, this is from a lady. I love it.
I love when the ladies write in. You guys don't do it enough. Um,
I've been listening to your podcast for a little over a year.
Basically since the day I discovered them and have seen all your specials.
Hope to catch a live one of these days. Well thank you. So here it goes.
I've been living for eight years and married for four of those years to a man
who was 21 years older than me. Yet.
We met when he was 45 and I was 23 and we have been together since Nia.
Can you do this one or no? You can. Okay. All right.
Um,
uh,
we have a two year old son and I am now 31 and he is 52.
Okay. I know many think that when they first heard my husband,
uh,
that my husband is well old enough as well old enough to be my father,
that it's some sort of sugar daddy situation,
which honestly is not the case at all. Our lives are quite simple.
We live in a four bedroom house. I own two soccer.
We own two soccer mom type vehicles.
The only expensive piece of jewelry to my name is my wedding ring and one would
not find a pair of red bottom shoes in my closet. But I digress.
Only so folks don't get the wrong picture. Uh, for the past year or so,
it seems like he is aged mentally in a drastic way.
Our Age difference was never an issue until the last year or so. Um,
aw look Uzi. Hey Buddy.
Hey Buddy. You Doing?
You're making a lot of racket out there, aren't ya? This is called a podcast.
Um, anyways, so anyways, now here's the deal. This, this lady,
uh, is married to this guy. He's, he's 21 years older.
Um, what's going on? Yeah, these, they had phones. He's looking at me like,
what is this? What is this? Um,
so if you're going to keep looking at me with that cute little smile,
how do I do this? Uh, alright. So,
uh, yeah, she was 23.
He was 45, so I guess he's 22 years old.
And when they met 23 and 45 yeah.
And now she's 31 and he's 52. I don't know.
Somehow he was 22 years old and now he's only 21 must be when their birthdays
are. But anyways, she said it wasn't a sugar daddy thing.
They don't really have a lot of money. They'll just live in a basic lifestyle.
All you got to stop smiling kid. Um,
I'm totally losing my train of thought here.
He just too adorable it to adorable for me to do this.
Yeah, I know. That's what, that's what my listeners are doing. Eh,
can you get through this please? Um,
so basically she said the only expensive of jewelry she has is her wedding ring.
She doesn't have any red bottom shoes. She just basically really loves the guy.
Okay. So, but for the past year or so,
it seems like he is aged mental mentally in a drastic way.
Our Age difference was never an issue until the last year or so.
He seems to be almost bitter than I am in my thirties and he's beginning to
become beyond insecure that I will decide I want a younger man out of nowhere.
One day, uh, I'm all over the place with this. She says,
it seems like you're pretty focused. Sorry. Anyways,
his constant insecurity in vastly changing behavior is really causing issues in
our marriage that I believe may never go away. Being that are age differences,
not going away anywhere.
Obviously was hoping for some of your wise input on my current situation or tell
me I'm a dumb ass for marrying an older man,
older man than my father.
Like my mother does a have a good one. And of course go fuck yourself.
Uh, so what do you think Nia?
Um, yeah,
he was probably too old for you because now that's just too much of an age,
but he's older than your dad. Do you have daddy issues? Maybe.
Well, regardless, it seems like the power dynamics have shifted.
So before you were a young, you know, impressionable thing and he was the older,
wiser, more in control. Now he's getting older,
he's becoming aware of his mortality. And you're in your thirties what?
You're like, you're towards your peak now as a woman.
Like that's when you really peak in.
You're actually in your forties but you're getting there.
You're probably still hot. You're smarter than you were before.
You're on top of your game where it's like, yeah, he's feeling some type of way.
So I don't know if he's having a midlife crisis. Yeah.
I don't know if he's having a midlife crisis and you're gonna end up being
collateral damage, um, or, or what's going on.
But you guys should probably have like a frank discussion about it. But yeah,
if he's afraid of you leaving him,
he might be having some kind of a midlife crisis. All right,
let's have the frank discussion for her. I'll be the guy. All right.
Oh you want to be the guy? No, you'd be that.
You'd be the guy cause you're the owner.
You're an actual older guy in our relationship. So I know it's true.
That's just like too on the nose. Castic no, it's okay. We can, we can,
we can do it that way. So you're the older guy and I'm the hot young,
new bile wife. Okay. A boy. You gonna go out where you gone?
You gone out with no, I gotta be older. I'm still, I'm just done. Good.
Where are you going? My girlfriends. I told you that. Did you not?
Do you not remember? Yeah, I remember that. Okay,
well I'll be bouncing [inaudible] I,
I told you last night that I was going out with my girlfriends tonight wearing
that. I'm going out.
I'll bring you back something by goes to have an affair with my young lover.
What do you think she should do? Just have a talk with him and if he's like,
what is that noise that's just shown a dump truck makes one,
it backs up before dumps the load up the back. Married the guys,
she shouldn't just like completely jumps ship.
But if it's like if he's becoming unbearable and you know,
difficult to live with and he won't make any strides to work it out,
then why doesn't he take like those legal roids that those old guys that are all
shredded, you know, they jump in the pool and they come out and all those,
those women who were sitting in the pool like look at that old guy and then he
comes out of the pool and they're like, oh wait a minute.
I think I'll bang that grandpa. Well maybe two,
because they're live like the severity, like modest lifestyle.
He's feeling even more insecure that he doesn't have anything to like offer.
So even if he wanted to get out of it to like go back to a younger girl or
something like younger than her, he wouldn't have anything necessarily to offer.
So it's the, this guy's an idiot. I wouldn't have married a girl that younger.
I remember the time before I met Uni, I was like, oh,
it was like 35 or something when it was when I was 25. You are 35. All right.
So I was like, whatever, 34 35 and I met this woman, right.
And she was like 22 2122 and she said the first night we hung out,
she goes, where is this going? I remember you told me this story. Yeah.
And I said, where's it going? I go nowhere.
I go when you're 30 and we'd be like 106 so this isn't going anywhere.
So I won't say what I said next, but it worked out well. Um,
all right. That's the, uh, that's the pocket. You this,
is there a new thing she just grabs? You got such a grip.
That's my forearm here that you just grabbed a whole handful of.
Um, all right. I want to hang out with her before you have to go to work.
So I gotta get off the thing here.
You're just fascinated with anything that's technology. There's no screen on it,
so that's boring, right? It's got a light on it. Let's go light on it. Oh,
it's got a light on it, doesn't it? Yeah.
I always think you can't get any cuter than you get. Cute, Huh? All right. Okay,
cool. Hang on a second. I'll hang out with you in a minute. All right.
That's the podcast. I'm,
I go f yourselves and I'll check in on you on Thursday. There.